these images show some of more than 800
police intelligence officers carrying
out an unprecedented raid in south
central chile
in an area dominated by indigenous
mapuches
on this farm police searching for
marijuana were attacked by unidentified
gunmen
one of the officers was killed although
his death
dominated national news it wasn't the
only violence that took place that day
these photos show police operatives
using what human rights experts call
illegitimate use of force and abuse
against minors
here the target was the seven-year-old
daughter of mapuche activist camilo
catrianka
he was killed two years ago by special
forces police
her mother and grandmother were also
thrown face down to the ground and
detained
this is not an exceptional or isolated
case it's part of
institutional violence practiced against
the mapuche people
in which children are also victims
police intelligence director hector
espinosa
denies that the child was detained and
insists that chilean police don't
mistreat miners
but this recording of a mapuche teenager
reportedly being grabbed by police
suggests otherwise you can hear the girl
being told she'll be killed if she
doesn't shut up
a prosecutor is now investigating
charges of alleged police abuse against
minors on the day of the massive raid
but with the government now under strong
pressure to declare
a state of siege in the rest of region a
lot of people
are afraid that things will get worse in
fact the army has already been given the
go-ahead to carry out patrols in the
area
alongside special forces police
situation the situation today is of
uncertainty
and fear for the safety of the children
the violation of mapuche children's
human rights is an intergenerational
problem
the children who yesterday experienced
violence from the state
are the parents of the children
experiencing it today
so the job of reparation and
reconciliation is very complex
the sharp increase in attacks by
unidentified armed groups
who claim to fight for mapuche land
rights has taken the conflict in
southern chile to a new level
and with no solution in sight a new
generation of mapuche children is
growing up with violence
fear and anger lucia newman al jazeera
santiago